herzlich Willkommen zu ZDF heute live
für 44 Milliarden Dollar hat Elon Musk
Twitter gekauft nach langem Hin und Her
dann hat er erstmal jede Menge Personal
gefeuert und man kann es sagen den
Kurznachrichtendienst quasi an den Rand
des abgrundsmanövriert und nun stellte
er sich dem sagen wir mal Votum des
Volkes nämlich eine Abstimmung durch die
Nutzerinnen und Nutzer ob er als Head of
twitter zurücktreten also den Chefsessel
Räumen sollte oder nicht und das
Ergebnis ist heute bekannt geworden
17,5 Millionen Nutzer stimmten ab das
Ergebnis viel eindeutig aus
57,5% rotierten mit ja also für einen
Rücktritt von Mast
42,5 % stimmten für einen verbleibt es
51-Jährigen als CEO
nun kann man sagen 17,5 Millionen das
ist jetzt nicht besonders viel Elon
Muskat allein 122 Millionen Follower und
trotzdem Muskat angekündigt sich anders
Abstimmungsergebnis zu halten halten zu
wollen seit bekannt werden das
Ergebnisses hat es aber noch keine
direkte Reaktion von Maske gegeben da
kann man also gespannt sein wir wollen
über das Votum sprechen über die Folgen
und den typen-maske Reden mit MRT Wissen
unserem USA Korrespondenten in
Washington und mit dem Medienforscher
Professor Matthias Kette Mann in
Innsbruck und natürlich wollen wir alle
fragen Kommentare Meinungen die es von
euch gibt gemeinsam diskutieren schickt
sie also einfach schnell her dann werden
wir drüber reden zunächst jetzt aber zu
Elma tevenson unserem Chor und Enten in
Washington Elmar was bedeutet diese
ganze Abstimmung und was bedeutet vor
allen Dingen das Ergebnis heute
zunächst mal Rätseln natürlich alle
darüber ob Maskes wirklich ernst meint
also ob er am Ende Butter bei die Fische
tut und dann tatsächlich zurücktritt wir
sehen momentan eine kleine
Achterbahnfahrt an der an der Börse in
New York beispielsweise dass die Tesla
Aktien heute morgen schon im
vorbörslichen Handel als die Umfrage
gelaufen war eigentlich hochgegangen
sind weil die Investoren erwartet haben
dass Mast tatsächlich seine Worte Ernst
seinen Worten Taten folgen lässt und als
Chef von Twitter aussteigt und dadurch
eben mehr zeitaufwenden kann sich um die
Probleme von Tesla zu kümmern sind die
Aktien hochgegangen dann sind Sie im
Laufe des Morgens eben weil er sich
nicht geäußert hat wieder runtergegangen
jetzt liegen sie wieder ein bisschen
besser also das Hin und Her tut
sicherlich Tesla überhaupt nicht gut und
das ist ja einer der hauptvorwürfe an
Elon Muster seine Obsession im Grunde
genommen fast zwanghafte Leidenschaft
besessen Inhalt sich um Twitter zu
kümmern ihn von eigentlich anderen und
auch sehr sehr wichtigen Aufgaben
ablenkt zum Beispiel die Leitung von
Tesla insofern rätseln alle herum und
wachten ob Elon Maskes am Ende
tatsächlich ernst meint was er da von
seinen Followern an Abstimmungsergebnis
bekommen hat wir können uns das El mal
was du gerade beschrieben hast auch mal
direkt als Bild anschauen nehme ich den
Verlauf der Tesla Aktie den Kurven
Verlauf in den letzten Wochen und
Monaten ging es eigentlich nur bergab
insofern sorgen Falten bei den Tesla
Mitarbeitern seitdem sich Elon Musk eben
um Twitter gekümmert hat für Twitter
gekämpft hat dann als CEO in alle
Richtungen gekämpft ausgeteilt hat
Kritik bekommen hat da hat man eben die
Bedenken gehabt du hast es schon gesagt
dass er sozusagen sich nur noch auf
Twitter konzentriert und nicht auf Tesla
ähm du hast es auch schon gesagt man
wird gespannt sein wie er denn jetzt mit
der Abstimmung umgeht ob er also seinen
Worten Taten folgen lässt
man wird das bei Tesla genauso
beobachten aber ganz allgemein lange
galt ja Elon Musk als Genie der eben wie
gesagt Tesla aus der Taufe gehoben hat
andere Dinge SpaceX und so weiter
geschaffen hat jetzt bekommen wir aber
einen ganz anderes Bild von ihm sorgt
das für Verwirrung für Rätselraten
ja ich glaube was da eine ganz große
Rolle spielt ist was für eine Art Chef
Typ er eigentlich ist er ist in der Tat
ein Genie sagen viele hat im Grunde
genommen den richtigen Riecher gehabt
als der Tesla gegründet hat und darauf
gesetzt hat eben diese Transformation
der Gesellschaft mit voranzutreiben in
diesem Fall Elektrofahrzeuge die am Ende
eben auch autonomen fahren können also
wo die Systeme so automatisiert sind
dass kein Fahrer mehr letztlich
eigentlich notwendig wäre also das ist
sicherlich sehr vorausschauend gewesen
aber jetzt wird es eng im Markt speziell
was Elektroautos angeht die großen
Konzerne ziehen nach Tesla kommt massiv
unter Druck und da er weiß sich eben
dieser Vorteil den Elon Musk hatte
alleine im Grunde genommen
Entscheidungen fällen zu können dass er
weiß sich jetzt als Nachteil er braucht
ein starkes Team er gilt nicht als Team
nicht als teamfähig das hat er auch
gerade bei Twitter bewiesen und
erratesche Entscheidungen fällen nach
Gusto das tut einer großen Firma Tesla
genauso wenig gut wie Twitter und
deswegen zweifelt man an den Fähigkeiten
von Elon Masters er in der Lage ist eine
Firma auch in schwierigen Situationen zu
führen und was Twitter angeht ist ja
lange nicht gesagt dass selbst wenn er
jemanden findet der die Leitung von
Twitter übernimmt dass er sich dann
wirklich raushält Elon Musk ist eben
einer der bis ins Kleinste bestimmen
will und deswegen sind auch die
Investoren skeptisch was das denn am
Ende bringt wenn er irgendjemanden
einsetzt als künftigen Chef von Twitter
aber letztlich immer noch selber seine
erotischen Entscheidungen dann
durchsetzen will aber wird sie
sicherlich auch in den USA auch eben bei
Testern woanders gefragt haben was ist
das für eine Attitüde von einem Chef der
eben ankommt für 44 Milliarden einen gut
funktionierendes Unternehmen kauft und
als erstes Mal und die Hälfte der
Belegschaft feuert vor allen Dingen in
der Spitzen Etagen
ja es zeigt im Grunde genommen dass er
die Hausarbeiten nicht macht für das was
eigentlich notwendig ist wenn man ein
großes ja Mitarbeiter starkes
Unternehmen das auch so eine
Weltbedeutung hat wenn man so ein
Unternehmen führen will er hat dafür man
kann es sagen hart bezahlen müssen und
zwar nicht nur dadurch dass er den
Status als reichster Mann der Welt
verloren hat er ist jetzt in
Anführungszeichen nur noch der
zweitreichste Mann der Welt mit einem
geschätzten Vermögen von zwischen 160
und 170 Milliarden Dollar aber was viel
entscheidender ist dass eben er durch
diese ich sag mal Eskapaden eine Menge
Vertrauen verspielt hat denn er braucht
letztlich auch Investoren um seine
Unternehmen voranzubringen die in seine
Technologie investieren und da haben
insbesondere die Investoren in Tesla in
der vergangenen in der Vergangenheit
heftigste Kritik geäußert tun das jetzt
eben auch wieder weil sie eben der
Meinung sind dass Elon Musk nicht das
tut was in der Führung eines
Unternehmens notwendig ist nämlich
gemeinsam mit einem Team Strategien zu
erarbeiten um auch in schwierigen Zeiten
dieses Unternehmen weiterhin erfolgreich
zu machen
erstmal für den Moment vielen Dank Elmar
Thesen in Washington denn Elmar wir
sprechen uns gleich noch wieder bevor
wir jetzt mit dem Medienforscher
Professor Matthias kettemann sprechen
der an der Universität Innsbruck ist
aber auch am Leibniz-Institut für
Medienforschung arbeitet ein Überblick
über eben die Elmar sagt so schön die
Eskapaden die Kapriolen von Elon Musk
seit dem Kauf von Twitter
mit einem Waschbecken durch die
Firmenzentrale in San Francisco so
beginnt Ende Oktober die Ära mask bei
Twitter nach langem hin und her oder wie
er es nannte the bird is Fried der Vogel
ist befreit schon vor der Übernahme
schwärmte mask von Twitter
diese Plattform ist so umfassend wie
möglich fast ganz Amerika ist dabei und
kommuniziert über Twitter hier können
die User eine gerechte Diskussion führen
Ideen und kreative Dinge teilen oder
Ihre Videos und Podcasts
Podcast nach der Übernahme zeigten Musk
sein wahres Gesicht er krempelt mehr
oder weniger den ganzen Laden um
schmeißt fast die komplette Chefetage
und die halbe Belegschaft raus verlangt
Geld für den blauen verifizierungshaken
mit teils skurrilen folgen
reaktiviert in gesperrten Account von
Exos Präsident Trump verbreitet Symbole
der Verschwörungstheoretiker von q-annon
wie diesen weißen Hasen hetzt gegen den
us-corona-experten vautschi und sperrt
konnten von kritischen Journalisten die
Folge immer mehr User verlassen Twitter
da gibt es keine durchdachte
Entscheidungsfindung sondern nur eine
Machtkonzentration bei der Entscheidung
was Meinungsfreiheit ist es braucht eine
unabhängiges Gremium nicht nur Elon Musk
der entscheidet welche Konten
suspendiert und welche zugelassen werden
wir sind einfach nicht gewöhnt das
Wirtschaftsbosse ein solches Tempo
vorlegen so transparent sind wie er am
Ende ist es aber eher genial als
chaotisch weil nach meiner Auffassung
die Schritte die er unternimmt im Großen
und Ganzen die richtigen Schritte sind
um das Netzwerk in Ordnung zu bringen
mittlerweile sind die Accounts der
Journalisten wieder freigeschaltet mask
hatte die Twitter-User darüber abstimmen
lassen und sich dem Votum gebeugt und
jetzt hat er über sich selbst abstimmen
lassen
ja Herr Professor kettenbeinwegrüßen Sie
ganz herzlich in Innsbruck sie sind
Medienforscher beobachten das ganze und
die Frage an Sie wie erklärt man dieses
ganze Hin und Her dieses wir haben es
gerade gehört dieses geniale und
chaotische bei Maske
also schönen guten Abend ich persönlich
halte das weniger für genial und mehr
für chaotisch und willkürlich und das
ist nicht die Art und Weise wie man eine
Plattform reguliert Plattformen brauchen
Vertrauen die brauchen klare Standards
die brauchen ethische und rechtliche
Regeln und die brauchen nicht einen
eratischen Menschen an der Spitze dem
seit 40 Jahren niemand gesagt hat nein
denke mal darüber nach was du tust
Meinungsäußerungen zu regulieren ist
hochkomplex der stellt sich jeden Tag
millionenfach eine neue Frage und und
was denkt dass er Twitter so behandeln
kann wie ein
ingenieurs-problem wie man einen
Menschen schnell zum Mars kriegt oder
eine gute Autobatterie baut aber
Meinungsäußerungen kann man nicht lösen
die stellen sich jeden Tag aufs Neue die
kann man nur mit Transparenz und einer
Rechtsstaatlichkeit begegnen und nicht
durch ratisches Chaos wie es aktuell bei
Twitter herrscht
wie lässt sich denn im Nachhinein auch
diese ganze Entlassungswelle erklären
wir haben schon gesagt da kommt jemand
an kauft ein funktionierendes gutes
Unternehmen und würde man vielleicht
sagen stellt sich vor und das erste was
er gemacht hat ist eben gerade in der
Führungsetage Kahlschlag jede Menge
Leute rauszuwerfen
ja das war glaube ich dem dem narrativ
geschuldet der Erzählung mit der er
angekommen ist er hat ja gemeint er wird
alles neu machen er wird
Meinungsfreiheit dort herrschen lassen
und vor allem bitte diese californischen
Moderatorin Moderatorinnen den wird er
das Handwerk legen die sind viel zu
liberal sein viel zu liberal und da ist
es durchaus folgerichtig dass er all
jeneuert die für das alte Twitter
gestanden sind nicht nur die Chefs und
Chefinnen für die Bereiche recht
Compliance Datenschutz sondern auch fast
das gesamte Menschenrechts Themen des
gesamte Team bis ich mit KI und Ethik
beschäftigt hat auch das Brüsseler Büro
Verbindungsbüro zur EU hat der hat der
gesperrt er wollte einfach jetzt dort
eine neue Welt designen und er musste
erkennen dass das sehr sehr schwierig
ist Meinungen zu regulieren Meinungs
Management zu betreiben ist einfach
schwerer als Menschen auf den Mars zu
setzen er ist ein inkompetenter
Regulierer der öffentlichen
meinungsmeinungs macht und das ist sehr
gefährlich wenn man so eine große ein
großes Podium hat wie Twitter es ist ich
hoffe dass er sich selbst dass er das
Wort dass er jetzt gegeben hat auch
jetzt hält er hat vor kurzem mal getötet
VOX profilbox.de die Stimme des Volkes
ist eigentlich die Stimme die zählt naja
jetzt hat das Volk abgestimmt
und jetzt lassen wir uns überraschen wie
die Reaktionen sind im Moment haben wir
noch nichts gehört ich habe gelesen
manche vermuten vielleicht sitzt er auch
noch im Flieger zurück vom
dm-finale in Katar war was er besucht
hat und das ist vielleicht ein längerer
Flug zurück man muss ja eben auch wissen
wen er da eben alles auch getroffen hat
emiere Recep Tayyip Erdogan man muss
verstehen dass die katari eben auch
Tesla mit finanzieren wenn ich das
richtig verstanden habe insofern ist es
auch keinen Zufall jetzt oder nur
Zeitvertreib wenn er da eben bei dem
Finale war jetzt ähm interpretiere ich
aber wenn sie sagen ja er hat geglaubt
so wie man das Elektromobilität Problem
mal eben lösen kann und ähm die
Raumfahrt revolutionieren kann so
revolutioniere ich jetzt sozusagen ja
Meinungsfreiheit und Meinungen im
Internet was eben schwieriger ist lese
ich da bei ihm jetzt also raus dass sie
sagen der Mann leidet an kräftiger
ja einerseits das was hier nicht
schlecht ist für für Leute die die große
Ideen haben wenn man gleich man gleich
über die Herausforderungen nachdenkt die
vor der SpaceX gestanden ist oder oder
Tesla dann war es am Anfang ganz gut
dass in diesen Bereichen sich nicht hat
nein sagen lassen aber man weiß dass
anderen Unternehmen dass er dort gute
Teams hatte die ihn beraten die ihn
abgefangen haben die seine Ideen in
umsetzbare
umsetzbare Unternehmenspolitik dann
gegossen haben das scheint bei Twitter
nicht so zu sein wie erleben in Echtzeit
mit wie er hier hin und her regiert und
das ist da muss ich dem Interviewten
vorher widersprechen das ist nicht
genial das ist gefährlich gefährlich und
inkompetent es gibt so viel gute gutes
Wissen wie man ordentlich moderiert
gerade auch bei Twitter wurde das
Kommentare angehäuft wie er das macht
ist das ist das nicht gut und auch das
Volk einfach so zu fragen ist nicht der
richtige Weg wenn auch mehr Demokratie
mehr Demokratisierung jeder Plattform
gut täte also wir haben schon
verschiedene fragen Kommentare Meinungen
eben auch hier was diese
Meinungsfreiheit angeht schreibt Roman
Romanowski über Youtube ich finde Elon
Musk super weil er die Meinungsfreiheit
wieder ermöglicht und nicht immer Zensur
macht wie der Rest also was das angeht
jemand der sozusagen applaudiert
auch till dorfschmidt schreibt über
Youtube Elon sorgt dafür dass man
kritische Meinung wieder frei äußern
kann das ist sehr wichtig und auch
richtig hate speech muss natürlich auch
über Elon Musk bekämpft werden war es
was was ist ja auch wird da müsste man
sie jetzt einfach noch mal fragen ist
das wirklich so denn wir haben ja ihn
selber gegen vgi wettern oder hetzen
hören wie auch wenn Sie das Ganze ein
was eben das Thema Meinungsfreiheit auf
der einen auf Twitter angeht und dann
eben doch auch Hetze und was eben nicht
so ganz unter Meinungsfreiheit fällt ja
also Plattformen über Twitter die können
gar nicht zensieren zensieren können nur
starten was die Plattformen können ist
nach bestimmten Regeln Inhalte erlauben
und nicht erlauben
twitter hat in der Vergangenheit zum
Beispiel Desinformationen zu Impfungen
etwa zu Wirksamkeit von corona-impfungen
gelöscht auch erst seit der Beginn der
corona-pandemie aber immerhin nun kann
man jetzt die Meinung vertreten wir
sollten mehr Meinungsfreiheit online
haben wir sollten Desinformationen zu
Impfungen erlauben diese Meinung kann
man haben die kann man vertreten aber
Unternehmen wie Twitter kann entscheiden
nein wir möchten nicht beitragen zum
Tode von mehr Menschen indem wir
Desinformationen verbreiten und das
finde ich ist eine gute Entscheidung den
respektieren muss ihre Maske das jetzt
revidiert und bekannt gegeben dass
Twitter
diese neue Regel dass man eben
Desinformationen zu Impfungen nicht
teilen darf nicht mehr umsetzt halte ich
für eine schlechte Entscheidung anders
zum Beispiel auf Facebook durfte man bis
2019 den Holocaust leugnen dann hat Mark
Zuckerberg entschlossen dass man das
dann nicht mehr darf ist das Zensur nein
das ist keine Zensur das ist ein
unternehmerische Entscheidung was
erlaubt wird und das nicht erlaubt wird
und in der Vergangenheit war es so dass
die Plattformen viel zu wenig moderiert
haben gerade in Staaten in Afrika und in
Asien auf Facebook wurde in Myanmar zum
Völkermord aufgerufen in Afrika sieht
man regelmäßig Hass Rede die zu offline
Tötungen für zu morden auch in
Deutschland gibt es dafür einzelne
Beispiele das Problem hier ist er das
einzelne Stimmen gerade aus dem rechten
Lager gerade die Republikaner in Amerika
sich auf den Schlips getreten fühlen
wenn Ihre Inhalte wegen Desinformation
gesperrt werden hingegen alle
empirischen Studien die es gibt belegen
dass die Plattformen eben nicht
ideologisch moderieren es aber so ist
dass von rechter Seite einfach mehr
Desinformationen produziert werden und
deswegen werden die proportional stärker
moderiert gelöscht gesperrt und dagegen
wollte
Twitter angehen dagegen wollte Musk bei
Twitter angehen und hat sich in Applaus
gerade der der rechten abgeholt in dem
hat er sich einige Zeit gesund und jetzt
hat er gemerkt dass ihm das Milliarden
kostet und auch nicht besonders Spaß
macht und das wird einer der Gründe sein
wenn man jetzt einen Weg nach ja in
einen Ausweg sucht sagen dass er gerade
Applaus indem er sich gesund hat dass er
sozusagen nicht fishing vor Komplements
oder vor Applaus könnte man jetzt sagen
ein Blick sozusagen oder versucht die
die Psyche ein bisschen zu analysieren
Handy Wichmann schreibt über Youtube
über ich hatte zu lange zu viel Erfolg
das vertragen die wenigsten Menschen
schon allein der Name seines Sohnes
spricht Bände über den Geisteszustand
des Vaters und Veronika Beck Schwarte
schreibt über Facebook ich finde Donald
Trump gefährlicher Elon Musk möchte
geliebt werden und Trump ist das wurscht
da ist der sich selber der Liebste aber
das Wichtige was hier Veronika schreibt
Elon Musk möchte geliebt werden ist das
wirklich so der Antrieb dass er
sozusagen angehimmelt werden möchte für
den nächsten genialen Erfolg oder ist da
irgendwie ja eine politische Strategie
dahinter
ich glaube nicht dass wir mit einem
Präsidentschaftskandidaten Elon Musk
rechnen müssen in Amerika schon allein
deswegen nicht weil er nicht
amerikanische
nicht dort geboren wurde
das hat auch schon einen Arnold
Schwarzenegger zum Beispiel daran
gehindert politisch aktiver zu werden
auch ein Gouverneur glaube ich nicht
dass er das werden möchte ich denke für
ihn war das jetzt einfach der Versuch
den Erfolg der letzten Jahre der sicher
auch zu Kopf gestiegen ist umzusetzen um
eine Plattform aufzukaufen um dort zu
zeigen was er also wie wie er Freiheit
versteht man muss aber immer dass sie
nicht man darf nicht vergessen er hat ja
sehr lange versucht aus dem Kauf wieder
rauszukommen er hatte also durchaus
Bedenken und hat versucht sich dem zu
entziehen dass er das Unternehmen kaufen
musste das hat nicht geklappt vor
Gericht wurde dann durchgesetzt dass er
einen bindenden Vertrag geschlossen hat
und jetzt
spezialisieren sich in gewisser Weise
auch seine seine Befürchtungen er hätte
es viel einfacher haben können indem man
das Unternehmen als Investition gesehen
hätte indem er die Teams die dort gut
eingeführt waren behalten hätte aber er
hat sich entschieden das anders zu
machen und es als ein sehr sehr teures
Hobby gesehen mit leider auch Folgen für
die für die online-diskurskultur
schauen wir aber einfach trotzdem mal
ganz kurz sie haben ja schon gesagt ja
zum Mars fliegen ist vielleicht
technisch einfacher aber er hat ja schon
Dinge geschafft die revolutionär gewesen
sind und wir schauen einfach mal auf das
was er geniales durchaus geschaffen hat
werfen einfach mal einen kompakten Blick
auf das Imperium von Elon Musk
geboren und aufgewachsen in Südafrika
wandert Elon Musk mit 17 Jahren nach
Nordamerika aus mit 24 geht er ins
Silicon Valley statt Studium an der
Stanford University gründet er mit
seinem Bruder seine erste Firma zip two
die unter anderem online stattführer
erstellt
1999 kauft die Firma compact das
Unternehmen für 307 Millionen US-Dollar
Elon Musk wird mit 28 Jahren zu
Millionär anschließend gründet er das
Online Bezahlsystem ex.com und
fusioniert es im Jahr 2000 mit einer
Konkurrenzfirma neuer Name PayPal eine
Fusion mit Erfolg schon zwei Jahre
später kauft ebay das Unternehmen für
1,5 Milliarden US-Dollar mit dem Geld
gründet Maske das Raumfahrt Unternehmen
SpaceX investiert 2004 in die
Elektroauto Firma Tesla und wird später
deren CEO das bleibt er bis heute und
mask gründet fast im Jahresrhythmus
weiter unternehmen 2015 die Firma op die
sich mit künstlicher Intelligenz
beschäftigt im Folgejahr the boring
company und neuralink das ein Gerät zur
Kommunikation zwischen Computer und
Gehirn entwickeln soll
nicht jedes Investment ist ein Erfolg
dass 2018 ins Leben gerufene
Medienunternehmen hat wird wieder
eingestellt
ob nun sein twitterkuh Erfolg oder fail
mit Folgen für sein gesamtes
Firmenimperium wird ist offen seit
kurzem gilt Elon Musk zumindest nur noch
als zweitreichster Mensch der Welt
fortsetzt sein Vermögen auf 164
Milliarden US-Dollar
[Musik]
es ist ja eindeutig hat eine Menge
geschaffen versucht eine ganze Menge hat
sehr viel Erfolg auch mal eben kein
Erfolg aber er hat doch eine ganze Menge
Zukunftstechnologie in der Hand Tesla
space X ist das ein Problem dass man so
doch auch auf diesen Mann setzt also die
NASA kann glaube ich ohne SpaceX nicht
viel machen derzeit und er hat ja doch
eine gewisse Bedeutung jetzt erkennt man
immer mehr eben was er eben doch für ein
Typ für ein Chef für ein Manager ist ist
das ein Problem
es ist nie gut es ist nie gut wenn man
nur auf einen einen Menschen eine Firma
eine Technologie setzt in der Tat ist es
aber so dass das amerikanische
Weltraumprogramm durch SpaceX einen
großen Boost erfahren hat und auch
unabhängige unabhängiger geworden ist
von von Russland und und China
insofern haben es gerade die
Mitarbeiterinnen von SpaceX nicht sehr
geschätzt wenn er mit seiner Toren da
ins in den in den Kleinkrieg gegangen
ist weil dir das Budget für space 6 mit
mitbestimmen das vom
Verteidigungsministerium dorthin fließt
ich denke eher dass seine Rolle noch
wachsen wird die Bedeutung der der
Technologie die der Beitrag angesprochen
wurden werden noch größer
GPS z.B das ist sehr erfolgreiche
online die die diese semantische
gesprächsmaschine die hat auch wenn er
Verbindungen die gerade jetzt populär
ist das heißt wir haben hier in vielen
Bereichen ist er sehr sehr gut
aufgestellt auch infrastrukturelle
Verantwortung auch in Zukunft zu tragen
ich glaube wir werden jetzt langsam zu
einem Punkt gelangen wo er bei Twitter
sich herauszieht es heißt sehr teures
meine teure Episode sehen wird aber sich
auch wieder verstärkt den anderen
Unternehmen widmen wird das wird dann
jeweiligen Aktionären gut tun und es
wird auch der amerikanischen Wirtschaft
gut tun die wie Sie angesprochen haben
in vielen Bereichen stark auf ihn setzt
und auf seine Unternehmen
aber noch mit einer Gegenfrage oder
einem Kommentar von tilldorf mit der
schreibt nämlich hat aufmerksam zugehört
und sagt kritisch was euer Experte also
Sie Herr Professor kennt man hier sagen
stimmt nicht man wurde auf Twitter
früher zensiert wenn man eine andere
Meinung zur Impfung oder CO2 hatte in
Sachen Klimaschutz das ist reine Zensur
kein hate speech was erwidern sie darauf
genauso wie nur ein Start foltern kann
kann nur ein Staat zensieren eine
Plattform kann moderieren und die kann
sagen bei mir zu Hause gilt das
Hausrecht mein Hausrecht und ich sage
bei mir darf man nicht Desinformationen
verbreiten sie können auch nicht zum
nächsten Aldi gehen und dort vor der
Fleischtheke einer Demonstration für
vegetarische Lebensweise starten das
können Sie vor dem Rathaus und wenn dann
die Polizei kommt und ihnen das Plakat
wegnimmt dann ist jetzt Zensur werden
sie zensiert nicht wenn Sie der
aldi-chef oder die alte Chefin rauswirft
und sagt aber geh bei mir können Sie das
nicht machen das ist das Äquivalent das
ist ein privater Raum natürlich hat er
eine öffentliche Bedeutung aber deine
privaten Raum gilt zunächst einmal
gelten die Regeln des jeweiligen
Unternehmens und er ist jetzt so wie
wenn ein privater Chef von heute auf
morgen neue Regeln aufstellt und einfach
mal das eine oder andere sagt die einen
rauswirft und dann die anderen und
einfach nicht mehr ansatzweise sich an
anderen Recht und Regeln hält und das
ist nicht gut Armin Passat Titel
reagiert auch da drauf sozusagen
stimmt dem ganzen zu und sagt
Warnhinweise über Fake News sind ja
jetzt nicht gleich Zensur stimmt ihnen
da also zu Herr Professor kettemann dann
ganz ganz herzlichen Dank ja für die
Analyse für den Blick auf Elon Musk und
wir sind alle gemeinsam gespannt wie es
weitergeht denn wir warten eigentlich
noch auf eine Reaktion ob er sozusagen
das Votum wir als versprochen hat
annimmt und was als nächstes passiert
ist bleibt also spannend wir werden das
weiter beobachten ganz herzlichen Dank
und viele Grüße nach Innsbruck tschüss
danke schön ja und wir gehen jetzt
einfach von Innsbruck über Mainz noch
mal direkt nach Washington zu Elma
devensen und wollen mit ihm auch noch
mal darüber sprechen Elma wir haben
schon darüber gesprochen und Professor
Kette Mann hat auch gesagt
Elon Muskat sehr viele Trump Anhänger
Verschwörungstheoretiker etc zu sich
rübergezogen
steckt da irgendetwas politisches
dahinter einen Plan oder ist das nur so
ein testen wie Professor Kette man es
gesagt hat ich will mal gucken wie viel
Applaus ich kriege wie viel Macht ich
habe zu bestimmen aus welcher Seite ich
Applaus kriege
also für mich wirkt das auch eher
erotisch und willkürlich was er da macht
der Professor kennemann hat eigentlich
völlig recht es gab bei Twitter über
viele Jahre erstens genaue Regeln die
sind auch verändert worden sind
angepasst worden ist aber niemand
einfach mal so von Twitter verbannt
worden sondern bei falschen
Informationen gab es in der Tat die
waren Hinweise das war's dann aber auch
wer Hass Hetze und Gewalt verbreitet
Gewalt Aufrufe der musste damit rechnen
tatsächlich von Twitter verbrannt zu
werden es gab auch eine Struktur die
darüber berät die auch transparent macht
nach welchen Kriterien vorgegangen wird
das alles hat Elon Musk unter dem Banner
der Meinungsfreiheit mal eben aufgelöst
und hat sich selber zu obersten Instanz
erklärt und hier liegt glaube ich das
Problem weil auf diese Weise natürlich
auch diejenigen wieder auf Twitter
unterwegs sind und das auch
unwidersprochen die Lügen verbreiten die
Hass verbreiten die Hetze verbreiten die
auch zu Gewalt aufrufen es gibt ein paar
Ausnahmen aus den letzten Wochen wo er
dann selber auch aktiv geworden ist zum
Beispiel als Kanye Western Hakenkreuze
verbreitet hat hat er ihn dann auch
sperren lassen von Twitter aber unterm
Strich sagen hier die Beobachter in den
USA hat Twitter schon vormask aber dann
noch mal ganz besonders unter Mars
leider ein gutes Stück dazu beigetragen
dass hier in Amerika die Zahl der
Hassverbrechen deutlich hochgegangen
sind weil eben Hetze teilweise
unwidersprochen verbreitet worden ist
und er hat ja jetzt konnten wieder
freigegeben die genau das tun
Antisemitismus Rassismus Hetze weiter
verbreiten und insofern bräuchte es
dringend wieder ein Gremium und klare
Kriterien und man darf jetzt gespannt
sein ob Elon Musk seine Lektion gelernt
hat also es gibt auch lese ich in den
berüchtigten Neonazi Andrew England da
haben Gerichte schon gesagt dass seine
antisemitische Verschwörungstheorien und
Hass reden gefährlich sind also das ist
da schon festgestellt worden und er darf
dank Maske wieder auf Twitter sich
ordentlich austoben oder wir können uns
das eben angucken dass Elon hier einfach
diesen ja ich sag mal berühmt
berüchtigten weißen Hasen postet
schreibt follow was eben in die Richtung
der
q-annon Anhänger geht Elmer vielleicht
kannst du uns mal erklären ist das das
kann ja nicht einfach nur Spaß sein das
ist ja schon
sicherlich bedacht gemacht was löst das
denn aus in diesen Kreisen
ja es löst tatsächlich Bewunderung für
Elon Musk aus das geht so weit dass in
diesen verschwörungskreisen von curanon
diskutiert wird ob vielleicht eigentlich
Elon Musk derjenige ist der Auserwählte
auf den alle gewartet haben und eben
nicht Donald Trump dessen Stern gerade
im Sinken begriffen ist auch bei den
Verschwörungstheoretikern von qanon und
Elon Musk könnte mit der macht dir jetzt
hat so wird auf einigen Plattform von
verbreitet könnte mit dieser macht ja
jetzt dafür sorgen dass diese Ansichten
diese Theorien dann zu Mainstream werden
die Anhänger sind ja überzeugt dass das
alles die pure Vase Wahrheit ist das ist
der pure Blödsinn und am Ende ist die
große Frage ob Elon must selber in
irgendeiner Weise auch daran glaubt oder
ob er nur Spaß daran hat diese
willkürliche Macht auszuüben und ob er
vielleicht doch am Ende zu der Einsicht
kommt dass er seinen extrem teurer und
ein gefährlicher Spaß ist weil dadurch
das haben wir ja hier in den USA gesehen
ein Stück weit auch die amerikanische
Demokratie gefährdet wird
aber das ist eben die Frage twitter ist
ja jetzt nicht die größte Plattform
von Zahlen her kleiner als tiktok
Instagram und so weiter und so weiter
aber es ist ja doch sagen wir mal die
Elite oder
Multiplikatoren die letzten Endes das
ganze benutzen kann er mit Twitter doch
zu einer politischen Macht werden oder
ist das ausgeschlossen weil er quasi nur
spielt
wenn er im Grunde genommen Freiraum
lässt und nur willkürlich hin und wieder
eingreift und möglicherweise eher dabei
ich sag mal rechtsextremistische oder
auch linksextremistische Ansichten im
Grunde genommen dann frei dort
vagabundieren lässt dann würde er
natürlich zu einer Polarisierung im Land
noch weiter beitragen ich glaube auch
wie Professor kenne man das ähm Elon
Musk mittlerweile darüber nachdenkt wie
sehr ihm das selber schadet ähm dass er
sich so unmittelbar überall hinein
möchte weil es tatsächlich schwieriger
ist so ein Meinungsfreiheit eine
Plattform im Grunde genommen die
Meinungsfreiheit auf dieser Plattform
mit zu verteidigen und seine Investoren
von Tesla werden ihm glaube ich es gibt
auch einige anhängende Gerichtsverfahren
werden ihm weiterhin sehr sehr klar
machen dass er als Geschäftsmann
möglicherweise auch seinen Erfolg
riskiert in Zukunft wenn er weiter in
diesem Bereich von Twitter so aktiv ist
und selber willkürlich die Entscheidung
fällt
jetzt ist es ja so in Europa wenn du
jetzt sagst Meinungsfreiheit Eingreifen
etc da gibt es ja dann doch mal irgendwo
jemand der sagt Stopp wir haben hier
auch nur gewisse Spielregeln die EU die
dann sagt so geht es aber nicht und das
müsste dann doch gelöscht werden also da
gibt es ja doch noch sozusagen eine
Institution jemand der Einhalt gebietet
wie ist das denn in den USA gibt's da
eigentlich sozusagen komplette Freiheit
für ihn oder gar keine Institution
niemanden der ihm Einhalt gebietet
also einerseits gilt das hier der
Begriff der Meinungsfreiheit in den USA
auch aus meiner Beobachtung extrem weit
ausgelegt wird da wird einiges
verbreitet was nach europäischen oder
auch deutschen Kriterien längs schon ich
sag mal mit Gegenwind rechnen müsste das
ist hier in den USA nicht so
beispielsweise können hier Neonazis
unter zeigen auch der Hakenkreuz Symbole
durch die Straßen marschieren was sie an
der ein oder anderen Stelle in den USA
auch tun aber jetzt kommt das aber es
gibt eine Lust im amerikanischen
Kongress schon zu schauen wie kann man
den großen Hightech Unternehmen allen
voran Twitter und Facebook diesen großen
Plattform auch ein Stück weit Einheit
Gebieten schärfere Regeln aufdrücken auf
oktouieren aber es reichen
möglicherweise am Ende im Kongress die
Mehrheiten dafür nicht wir haben ja ein
Kongress der gespalten ist fast fifty
fifty in beiden Häusern das Kongresses
hier in Washington ähnliches ist in
vielen Bundesstaaten der Fall das heißt
wenn man wirklich wirksam ein Gesetz
verabschieden wollte was in diesem Fall
eben Regularien vorschreibt dann müsste
man eine größere Mehrheit haben und bei
dieser Polarisierung im Land ist diese
Mehrheit auch aus meiner Beobachtung
derzeit nicht in Sicht tja Eva insofern
auch die Analyse der politischen
Situation in den USA letzte Frage wie
wird denn nun weitergehen Blicke die
Kristallkugel mit Elon Musk was macht
ein Mensch der sich wir haben es gesagt
für ein Genie hält
wenn er aber nun als CEO abgewählt
worden ist man kann sagen zumindest
diesen einen Karren Twitter so ein
bisschen gegen die Wand gefahren hat was
würdest du vermuten
ja ich kann nicht in den Kopf von Elon
Musk schauen ich glaube am Ende ist ja
eigentlich ein Narzisst wie Donald Trump
das ist das heißt er will schon ich sag
mal bewundert werden ein Stück weit und
merkt jetzt dass er eine Menge Gegenwind
kassiert auch von vermeintlichen
Anhängern und vor allen Dingen von
seinen Investoren ich glaube dass er
weil so viel auf dem Spiel steht Tesla
und SpaceX sind die ich sag mal
Milchkühe in seinem Konzern die im
Grunde genommen das meiste an Zukunft
Erfolg versprechen dass er zur Besinnung
kommt und versucht das was bei Twitter
passiert wieder ein bisschen in
organisierte Bahnen zu lenken aber das
ist eine wilde Vermutung wir wissen es
nicht Elon Musk ist einerseits ein Genie
ich bleibe dabei was die
Zukunftstechnologien angeht und das
voranzutreiben andererseits aber ganz
offenbar ein willkürlicher Narzisst und
das lässt im Grunde genommen alle
Möglichkeiten offen
dann sind wir wie gesagt gespannt was
passieren wird wenn Elon Musk sich dann
meldet ob er das Votum annimmt und wie
es mit ihm weitergeht ich danke
jedenfalls ganz ganz ganz herzlich
vielen Dank nach Washington el matthesen
für die Analyse für den Background und
die Informationen vielen Dank Elmar
ja und das war unser Livestream ZDF
heute live zu Elon Musk mit dem Votum
heute ich wiederholst noch mal 57,5 %
haben gesagt Elon trete zurück und wir
werden sehen was er denn nun macht er
hat zumindest ja angekündigt gehabt er
werde in diesem Votum Folgen vielen
vielen Dank für das Interesse schönen
Abend noch tschüss